stell dir vor du wachst eines tages auf
und merkst
irgendetwas stimmt hier nicht kurzum
tafel bin ich ist dieser mann
[Musik]
und warum bin ich durch schläuche mit
ihm verbunden
eine ärztin erklärt dir deine lage der
mann neben dir ist weltberühmt er ist
ein star geiger
doch er schwebt in lebensgefahr
er leidet an einer tödlichen
nierenkrankheit seit tagen schon wartet
er auf blut die zeit drängt doch dann
gestern abend ein paar seiner größten
fans bringen dich zu uns ins krankenhaus
du hast als einzige person exakt die
selbe blutgruppe das zusammenschließen
eurer beiden blutkreisläufe ist seine
letzte chance sonst wird er sterben
du kannst ihm das leben retten nur du
wie bitte auf einmal erinnerst du dich
[Musik]
die fans des geigers haben mich gestern
abend entführt und ins krankenhaus
gebracht
die ärztin kann es kaum glauben man hat
dich gekidnappt um den geiger zu retten
du willst dich von den schläuchen
befreien nichts wie raus hier
doch die ärztin beschwichtigt sobald du
dich von den schläuchen lösen solltest
wird der geiger sterben du würdest ihn
töten
das darfst du nicht sie versucht dich zu
beruhigen indem sie dir versichert die
therapie dauert nicht ewig sondern bloß
neun monate danach ist der geiger wieder
in topform und du kannst nach hause
gehen
also was tust du weißt du die infusionen
raus oder hast du neun monate im bett
aus was wiegt schwerer
das lebensrecht des geigers oder dein
recht auf selbstbestimmung ein ähnliches
dilemma stellt sich im fall der
abtreibung bei ungewollten
schwangerschaften meinen einige
philosophen bei schwangerschaften etwa
die auf das versagen von
verhütungsmitteln oder gar auf
vergewaltigung zurückzuführen sind
das leben des ungeborenen kindes hängt
dann von der schwangeren frau ab ähnlich
wie der geiger von dir und angenommen
dass um geboren hat bereits ein
lebensrecht dann stellt sich die frage
welches recht wiegt stärke
das lebensrecht des fötus oder das recht
auf selbstbestimmung der schwangeren
frau
[Musik]